GUTFELD.
IT'S 5 O'CLOCK IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS IS THE "THE FIVE."
IT JUST WON'T GO AWAY.
A YEAR AND A HALF SINCE LOSING
THE ELECTION, HILLARY CLINTON IS
STILL COMPLAINING.
GIVING A SPEECH AT RUTGERS
UNIVERSITY, SHE GRIPED ABOUT
GETTING TROUNCED BY TRUMP.
>> THE ELECTION WAS PRETTY
TRAUMATIC.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> BECAUSE OF WHAT HAD BEEN
EXPECTED TO HAPPEN IN THE
ELECTION WHICH OBVIOUSLY DID
NOT.
THEN A LOT OF ANGST AND SECOND
GUESSING AND FINGER POINTING.
>> CLINTON HIT BACK AT CRITICS
WHO TOLD HER TO SHUT UP BY
CRYING SEXISM.
>> I WAS REALLY STRUCK HOW
PEOPLE SAID THAT TO ME.
MOSTLY PEOPLE IN THE PRESS.
FOR WHATEVER REASON.
GO AWAY.
THEY NEVER SAID THAT TO ANY MAN
WHO WAS NOT ELECTED.
AL GORE DIDN'T STOP TALKING
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND MITT
ROMNEY IS RUNNING FOR THE
SENATE.
I AM REALLY COMMITTED TO
SPEAKING OUT AND DOING WHAT I
CAN TO HAVE A VOICE IN THE
DEBATE ABOUT WHERE OUR COUNTRY
IS GOING.
>> KIMBERLY, YOU ARE SIGHING
OVER THERE.
>> I WAS TRYING TO DO
MEDITATION.
INHALE AND EXHALE.
IT DIDN'T WORK.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
I JUST FIND HER VERY
AGGRAVATING.
NOBODY LIKES A SORE LOSER.
MAN OR WOMAN, IT DOESN'T MATTER.
A CANDIDATE.
YOU RAN, YOU DID WHAT YOU
THOUGHT WAS YOUR BEST.
YOU CAME UP SHORT.
NEVERTHELESS, NOW SHE IS PUSHING
BACK AGAINST HER OWN PARTY WHO
IS FRUSTRATED BY HER OWN
RHETORIC AND THEY ARE STEPPING
AWAY FROM HER.
I AM NOT SAYING SHE SHOULD GO
AWAY.
LET HER DO WHATEVER SHE WANTS, I
DON'T KNOW IT'S HELPING HER CASE
AND IT FOR SURE IS NOT HELPING
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> SHE POINTS OUT THAT IT'S NOT
JUST PEOPLE IN THE PRESS SAYING
SHUT UP.
IT'S DEMOCRATS.
>> IT'S NOT JUST HERE AT FOX
NEWS.
IT WAS McCASKIL, THE DEMOCRAT
FROM MISSOURI.
A 2-TERM SENATOR RUNNING FOR
ANOTHER TERM IN A TOUGH RACE.
MISSOURI PRESIDENT TRUMP WON IT
BY DOUBLE DIGITS.
SHE HAS TO APPEAL TO VOTERS THAT
HILLARY CLINTON CALLED
DEPLORABLE.
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO HILLARY
CLINTON REMINDED EVERYBODY ABOUT
THAT COMMENT AND DOUBLED DOWN ON
IT.
SHE MENTIONED AL GORE.
IF ANYONE HAD A REASON TO BE A
SORE LOSER, IT WILL BE GORE.
>> YES.
>> HE DID STAY IN THE PUBLIC EYE
BUT NOT ABOUT THE RECOUNT.
HE CHOSE AN ISSUE.
IT WAS CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE MADE FUN OF HIM FOR IT, BUT
HE WASN'T TRYING TO RELITIGATE
THE 2000 ELECTION.
HE WAS GRACIOUS AND MOVED ON
THAT.
HELPED THE COUNTRY TO BE MOVE ON
AND TO UNITE AFTER 9-11.
>> IT SEEMED TO ME HE TOOK A
YEAR OR YEAR AND A HALF OFF
BEFORE REEMERGING WITH THE
PERIOD AND TALKING ABOUT THE
CLIMATE AND THE IRAQ WAR.
HE DID LAY LOW UNLIKE MRS.
CLINTON.
>> YES, NONE OF HER EXAMPLES
HOLD WATER.
GORE'S PET CAUSE WAS NOT
HIMSELF.
HER PET CAUSE IS HERSELF.
IF YOU LOOK AT JOHN McCAIN HE
WENT BACK TO WORK AS WELL.
I DISAGREE STRONGLY WITH
KIMBERLY.
I THINK HILLARY CLINTON IS AN
AMERICAN HERO.
I LOVE HERE.
HE SHE IS LIKE THE POLITICAL
VERSION OF JASON FROM "FRIDAY
THE 13TH."
IF ONLY SHE HAD THIS KIND OF
ENERGY DURING THE ACTUAL
CAMPAIGN, HE WOULD BE PRESIDENT.
JUAN NAILED ME ON THIS.
I DON'T WANT HER TO GO AWAY.
THE MORE SHE IS AROUND, THE
WORSE IT LOOKS FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> JUAN?
>> THAT'S WHAT IS GOING ON HERE
TODAY.
[LAUGHING].
>> OH, IT IS, INDEED.
>> YOU ARE HAVING QUITE A PARTY.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> AT LEAST IT'S NOT A PITY
PARTY.
>> IT'S LIKE YOU ARE TRYING TO
BEAT A SO-CALLED DEAD HORSE.
>> ARE YOU CALLING HER A DEAD
HORSE?
>> WHOA!
>> GUESS WHAT, SHE DIDN'T WIN.
SHE IS NOT THE PRESIDENT.
SHE IS OUT THERE.
IT'S A TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE NOT
ONLY FOR HILLARY CLINTON BUT FOR
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
I THINK YOU LOVE HER AS THE
BOOGEYMAN.
SHE WAS ASKED AN INTERESTING
QUESTION.
SHE ONLY TOOK LIKE $25,000 FOR
THE SPEECH.
PAID LESS THAN SCHNOOKIE TO GO
TO RUTGERS.
>> THAT HURTS.
>> SHE WAS ASKED WHAT SHE WOULD
DO ABOUT POWERFUL FORCES
AFFECTING THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
SHE SAID THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
COMING UNDONE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
IF YOU DON'T RUN FOR THE FAR
RIGHT, YOU CAN'T BE A MODERATE
OR YOU WILL BE VILIFIED.
>> THE ONLY THING I SAY IT'S
HARD TO COME UNDOWN WHEN YOU
HAVE THE HOUSE, SENATE AND THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> NO, IT ISN'T.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THE HIGH NUMBER, 23
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS ARE
RETIRING.
GETTING OUT.
IT'S THE HIGHEST NUMBER SINCE
1973.
WHAT HAPPENED IN '73?
WATERGATE.
RICHARD NIXON.
PEOPLE ARE PUSHING AWAY FROM THE
HEART OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
AND OTHERS LOOK INTO THE FISA
ABUSES.
THAT'S ANOTHER STORY FOR ANOTHER
TIME.
LET'S HEAR ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON
TALK ABOUT THE WORLD UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> RIGHT NOW I AM MORE WORRIED
ABOUT WHETHER OUR CONSTITUTION
IS GOING TO BE HONORED.
WHETHER WE LEA
WHETHER WE LE
WHETHER WE WI
WHETHER WE WILL
WHETHER WE WILL S
WHETHER WE WILL SEE
WHETHER WE WILL SEE T
WHETHER WE WILL SEE THE
WHETHER WE WILL SEE THE R
WHETHER WE WILL SEE THE RUL
WHETHER WE WILL SEE THE RULE
WHETHER WE WILL SEE THE RULE O
WHETHER WE WILL SEE THE RULE OF
LAW PROTECTED.
WHETHER WE WILL HAVE THE
PREDICTABILITY AND STABILITY
THAT WE NEED IN FOREIGN AFFAIRS.
AS A FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE,
I AM DEEPLY WORRIED ABOUT THE
LOSS OF LEADERSHIP AND LEVERAGE
THAT THE UNITED STATES IS
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING.
>> IT'S FUNNY TO HEAR HILLARY
CLINTON TALK ABOUT RESPECTING
THE RULE OF LAW.
>> NOW YOU ARE FREAKING ME OUT.
>> CROOKED KIMBERLY.
>> YEAH.
>> I WON'T MIND.
I WILL ESCAPISM I LOVE THIS.
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION.
SO AM I AND THE PEOPLE TRYING TO
TEAR DOWN THE SECOND AMENDMENT
AND NOT LOOKING AT THE FULL
SPECTRUM TO MAKE SCHOOLS AND
OTHER SOFT TARGETS SAFE FOR
CHILDREN WHETHER IT'S A MOVIE
THEATER.
SHE IS CONCERNED ABOUT THE RULE
OF LAW.
SO AM I.
WHY IS THERE LAWLESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND SANCTUARY CITIES?
THEY WANT TO MAKE THEIR OWN LAWS
INSTEAD OF FOLLOWING THOSE ON
THE BOOKS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS LOOKING OUT
FOR THE CONSTITUTION TO SUPPORT
IT AND IS MAKING SURE THE
FEDERAL LAW IS ENFORCED.
RELATEDED TO FOREIGN POLICY,
SORRY, HILLARY CLINTON WE ARE
BETTER OFF THAN WHEN YOU WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WERE IN CHARGE.
NOW WE HAVE EFFECTIVE FOREIGN
POLICY.
LOOK AT RUSSIA AND NORTH KOREA.
THINGS ARE GETTING CLEANED UP NO
THANKS TO THE MESS YOU MADE.
>> WOW!
>> I AGREE WITH THE LADY OVER
THERE.